la pauvreté est un problème mondial
comment le résoudre à
la chine ce pays de plus de 1,4 milliard
d'habitants fait de gros efforts pour
lutter contre la pauvreté
la journaliste anna nedeljko entreprend
un voyage à travers la province du
fujian dans le sud-est de la chine
elle y parcourt ces hautes montagnes sa
mère
on semble dans les cordes et goûtent aux
difficultés du quotidien des fermiers
je n'aurais jamais cru que les ignames
puisse ressembler ce afin de tenter de
lever le voile sur le secret du miracle
économique chinois je n'ai jamais été
dans une maison comme ça il faut faire
très attention pour le bâton risque
et comprendre comment sortir un peuple
de la pauvreté
le projet est le china apporte quelques
réponses
la province de fujian se trouve dans le
sud est de la chine presque tout son
territoire est couvert de chaînes de
montagnes mais cette province possède
également le littoral le plus escarpés
de chine la mère héros dans la terre se
rapproche des montagnes la proportion de
surfaces agricoles par habitant est
l'une des plus faibles de chine la
pauvreté a donc toujours été le lot de
ses habitants mais les temps changent
dans cet épisode je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi une usine de bonbons ressemble
un bloc opératoire j'ai déjà un peu peur
et vous présentez un paysan qui est
devenu directeur d'une immense usine
we dance le président russe lui-même a
remarqué nos produits dans non je vais
aller voir pourquoi les patates douces
sont cultivés dans l'eau
[Musique]
je suis à ginger l'un des plus grands
centres industriels de la province de
fujian
la ville abrite de nombreuses marques
chinoises mais les usines et fabrique
également des vêtements et des
chaussures pour de célèbres entreprises
étrangères
[Musique]
jing zhang est également célèbre pour
son industrie agroalimentaire
l'un des producteurs le plus connu de
chine pas en panne corpore chaîne est
basé ici
[Musique]
ce n'est pas un hasard si nous avons
opté pour cette usine elle figure sur la
liste des 500 meilleures entreprises
d'asie je ne suis jamais allé dans une
véritable usine de produits alimentaires
auparavant mon objectif est de trouver
mon chemin dans le saint des saints un
endroit où aucune personne ordinaire
n'est autorisé à entrer là où sont
fabriqués toutes sortes de pâtisseries
et de bonbons
bonjour bonjour ravis de vous accueillir
bonjour à chanter
entre et je vous en prie
kaixi yann possède sept usines c'est
l'un des plus riches entrepreneurs de
chine et comme vous pouvez l'imaginer
c'est un homme très occupé il m'a
accordé un peu de son temps pour nous
présenter son usine
que nous allons entrer dans un atelier
où règnent des normes sanitaires et
hygiéniques très strict
je vous demanderais de mettre une blouse
un cas lourd des cours aux chaussures et
hamas
je suis prête à enfiler des vêtements
spéciaux nous essayons
c'est bon ça me va pas mal non génial
j'ai l'impression d'être dans une salle
d'opération plutôt que dans une usine
c'est sérieux on ne peut pas juste entré
comme ça
mais il s'est avéré que ces vêtements
n'était qu'un début la romana d'accord
on va passer à l'atelier
je suis prête
là c'est quoi l'endroit où on se lave
les mains il faut aussi se laver les
mains on se lave les mains ici on se
lave soigneusement les mains et puis on
les trempe dans une bassine de l'équipe
antibactérien
j'ai un peu peur des préparatifs aussi
sérieux tout ça pour entrer dans un
atelier
[Musique]
donc maintenant vous pouvez à nouveau
vous laver les mains
et là je vais enfiler les gants
[Musique]
avant d'entrer il faut passer par
plusieurs étapes là nous entrons dans
une sorte d'ascenseur
oh mon dieu qu'est ce que c'est que ça
l'ascenseur était en vérité une chambre
de décontamination avec de puissants
jets d'air provenant des murs
je veux à ses cheveux comme ça à la
maison
je peux dire que l'air est également
plaint d'un petit micro bien parce qu'il
ya une odeur spéciale
enfin les portes s'ouvrent
didon
ceci notre ligne de production
commençons notre visite par là
nous sommes dans une assez grande salle
qui fait plus de 100 mètres de long
sur le tapis roulant on distingue une
pâte jaune qui a une odeur familière
je pense que ce sont des chips
je n'ai jamais vu comment on fabrique
les chips presque tout le monde aime les
chips du moins tout le monde connaît
leur goût mais comment sont elles
fabriquées
on place les ingrédients là
pour un traitement préliminaire
c'est de la pomme de terre
de l'orge décortiquer et du kin wah
un mélange très savoureux
c'est à partir de ces trois ingrédients
qu'on fait la patte pour les chips le
tapis roulant la transporte ensuite vers
la phase suivante du traitement tout est
automatisé
le nombre d'employés dans l'atelier est
réduit au minimum
c'est magique comme machine
j'espère que je pourrai au moins un
goûter une
ensuite la pâte est compressé en
feuilles au départ ça a l'air un peu
épais
suite un pressage supplémentaire chaque
feuille attend l'épaisseur souhaité
et voici à quoi doit ressembler la patte
avant le traitement final si on sèche
c'est énorme feuilles ça fera une énorme
chip soc
ensuite les feux de pâtes sont découpés
en rondelles
je peux essayer non pas pour l'instant
c'est cru
ses chips se passe dans un livre ce four
j'ai hâte de lego tu es quand elles
seront prêtes mais pour le moment ce ne
sont que des petits morceaux de pâte
crue ça ne donne pas très envie
passons à la salle suivante
les chips sont séchées dans un énorme au
four de 60 mètres de long une fois un
froid dit elles sont enfin prêtes à être
dégustées
notre production est sorti du four
c'est la saveur écrevisses épicé
le produit est fabriqué à partir de
plusieurs types de grains entiers et
d'huiles végétales
tous les assaisonnements sont faits à
partir des meilleurs ingrédients
difficile de respirer avec autant des
pistes dans l'air
elles ne sont pas très salée elles sont
à la fois sucré et épicé allez il faut
que je goûte
c'est délicieux
pour la première fois de ma vie j'ai vu
comment faisait les chips moi qui ai les
adore mais ce n'est qu'une petite partie
de ce que produit cette méga société
imaginez un million de tonnes de
produits alimentaires sont fabriqués ici
chaque année
vous savez la chine compte 1 milliard
400 millions d'habitants par conséquent
son marché alimentaire un énorme
potentiel
en célèbre dicton chinois dit les gens
adorent la nourriture comme le ciel
notre entreprise s'efforce donc de
mettre sur le marché des produits sains
nutritifs et de haute qualité
nous sommes maintenant entrés sur le
marché international et approvisionnons
non seulement les clients chinois mais
également plus de 40 pays et régions
depuis plus de 20 ans ça y est ça
société participe activement un
programme gouvernemental conçu pour
aider les régions sous développées
comme beaucoup de choses en chine ce
programme a un an poétique lé bon lamer
aux montagnes et laissons les montagnes
descendre jusqu'à la mer
ces dernières années notre société a
aidé des milliers de personnes à
réaliser leurs rêves et à entrer à
l'université
l'entreprise utilise également la
puissance de sa marque pour stimuler le
développement dans les localités pauvres
et nous aidons en particulier le comté
de chantier
la ville de chongqing est située à 350
km de jinjiang c'est une région pauvre
montagneuse qui vit principalement de
l'agriculture
la société alimentaire de tsai et a
construit une grande usine pour aider
les habitants sortir de la pauvreté
hb anting 95% de nos employés sont des
habitants
à grâce au soutien de l'entreprise se
sont devenus des spécialistes hautement
qualifiés de la production de thurso
j'ai rencontré l'un de ces spécialistes
dans un entrepôt monsieur owens est
chargé de l'expédition des produits
finis
le camion est prêt oui je de la
marchandise est prête aussi oui oui
c'est bon c'est bien continuer à charger
je vérifierai plus tard
l'histoire de won est assez remarquable
il vient d'une famille très pauvre du
côté de chant thing one a travaillé dur
tout un étudiant pour obtenir un diplôme
universitaire il est maintenant
directeur financier adjoint de toute
cette société
voit aussi avant je travaillais dans un
entrepôt quand j'ai rejoint l'entreprise
je travaillais dans un atelier
notre patron m'a offert beaucoup de
bonnes opportunités
et je suis lentement monter en grade
poissons de comptable à directeur
adjoint
une fois sortie de l'entrepôt messieurs
wang m'inviter voir le show room as
combien de produits différents avez-vous
là il y en a plus de 50 dans neuf
catégories qui autorise mais si on parle
de l'ensemble de notre production dans
le pays ils on trouverait plus de 1000
mais il y a quelque chose dans la
société et particulièrement fier quelque
chose qui a un rapport avec le président
russe vladimir poutine
lors d'une réunion des dirigeants des
brics à xiamen le président poutine a
lui-même remarqué nos produits
hakim puis je me demande quel genre de
biscuits j'aimerais essayer ainsi
possible
il a par exemple apprécier ces biscuits
là lors du sommet
j'ai peu goûté oui
passé merci
c'est très bon pendant la dégustation
des biscuits j'apprends qu'une nouvelle
connaissance se rendra bientôt à
chongqing sa ville natale qui reçoit
temps de soutien de l'entreprise
j'ai hâte de voir de mes propres yeux
comment les grandes villes aide les
paysans
vous voulez venir avec moi vous voyez
c'est possible oui d'accord bon c'est
bien génial au liban
[Musique]
le lendemain ou ang et moi allons à sa
ville natale la route prendra quatre
heures
du mans
je n'y vais plus très souvent à cause de
mon travail mais mes parents ils vivent
toujours il me manque beaucoup
j'ai grandi dans une famille nombreuse
c'était dur pour nous à l'époque
[Musique]
du pigeonnier
du bois scianna elle vient de russie
anna voici mon père et mon oncle un
chanter et mon petit frère
c'est du thé merci c'était la tradition
cannes
où on vient d'un village caché dans une
étroite vallée entourée de basse
montagne
je m'attendais à voir une petite hutte
mais je suis tombé sur une grande maison
moderne
à la 2 voici notre nouvelle maison je
vois que vous venez de la terminer oui
ça vient d'être terminé mon père mon
oncle et mon frère cadet des ménages ici
maintenant et vous habitiez au avant
notre maison précédente juste à côté on
peut l'avoir bien sûr
c'est vrai l'ancienne maison de la
famille wang se trouve à proximité juste
en face
une vraie maison de campagne
un intéressant c'est notre ancienne
maison quand j'étais enfant c'était ma
chambre et si elle craint
alors nous sommes six dans la famille et
nous vivions tous ici thiam autodata oui
ça se voit que vous viviez très
pauvrement
[Musique]
oh
one arrivé d'échapper à la pauvreté
toute son enfance
il a été le meilleur élève de son école
d'abord puis de l'université
les membres de la famille de roms sont
des paysans ordinaire ils ont travaillé
dans ce jardin toute leur vie cultivant
du riz des pommes de terre et de la
canne à sucre
one se souvient que la canne à sucre
était considérée comme un mets de choix
moi j'en parle plus je peux goûter ça
bien sûr alors
ouais je sais très bon et c'est sucré
c'est quoi c'est du sucre brun en
produit par mon père en asie c'est comme
le chocolat c'est très nutritif c'est
sucré mais ça ressemble plutôt à des
bonbonnes cas du sucre par an même si on
a rejoint la direction de la plus grande
entreprise de la région il reste un
homme de la campagne
regardez comment ils admirent sa terre
vous voyez quel genre de sol nous avons
il est très bon trop fêtard
notre sucre est excellent parce que
notre terre n'a pas souffert de
l'érosion c'est bien conservé donc tout
pousse bien
l'érosion est l'un des plus grands
fléaux de cette région quand on était
enfant son village a été fortement
touché la forêt ne cessé de rétrécir les
pluies emporté la gauche fertile
les glissements de terrain enfouissez
les champs dans le sable
le gouvernement a alors élaboré un
programme pour sauver les terres
agricoles le problème a été presque
éliminé dans les plaines maintenant il
est temps de s'y attaquer dans les
montagnes si vous comparez notre terre à
celles des zones montagneuses vous
verrez que le seul là-bas est tellement
érodée q rien n'y pousse à tirer un
petit détour de tons couleur pour un
savoir plus sur l'érosion et les moyens
de la combattre or on m'a recommandé de
me rendre dans les montagnes voisines au
des travaux sont actuellement en cours
pour fortifier des pentes à côté de son
village j'ai hâte de rencontrer les gens
qui mènent cette lutte incessante contre
l'érosion des sols
[Musique]
l'un des principaux problèmes de cette
zone est la déshydratation du sol les
paysans vivent de la terre si le sol est
pauvre ils le sont aussi
la lutte pour la terre dans le comté de
chant thing est également une lutte
contre la pauvreté lyon
je dois gravir une pente assez raide
pour trouver ceux qui se battent contre
l'érosion
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tout en haut je rencontre une équipe
d'ouvriers locaux dirigés par hué
achetons pièce que l'érosion et pourquoi
ce phénomène se produit-il l'érosion du
sol se produit lorsque le couvert
végétal est perturbé où la végétation
est détruite l'excès d'eau affecte le
sol l'eau coule vers le bas formant des
dépressions et des ravins
mais pourquoi est ce si dangereux
l'un des problèmes auxquels les
agriculteurs sont confrontés à cause de
l'érosion des sols et le sable qui
recouvrent leur champ trop large les
chars malgré un travail acharné les gens
ordinaires font face à des pertes
la production en souffle et le niveau de
vie des villageois baisse terme à
la lutte pour le sol est donc aussi une
lutte contre la pauvreté
au début des années 2000 la chine a
adopté un programme spécial de lutte
contre l'érosion et le gouvernement
dépense sans compter
début 2000 on nous a attribué 10
millions de yuans par an et ce jusqu'en
arrières dupuy 2012 l'investissement
augmenté de manière significative
atteignant les 80 millions de yuan par
chalon
grâce à cela l'environnement s'est
amélioré significativement et la terre
est devenue plus fertiles
des villes riches comme jinzhang aide
également les zones rurales sous
développés comme champ thing en
partageant leurs expériences et en
envoyant des spécialistes compétents
[Applaudissements]
ce trou est trop petit
il n'est ni assez profond ni assez large
le semis ne prendra pas racine l'attend
essayer de creuser ici
ensuite nous devrons tout assez
oui c'est ça
le moyen le plus courant de voter contre
l'érosion est de renforcer les pentes en
plantant des arbres et des buissons mais
pour le faire efficacement il faut bien
comprendre quels types de plantes
caducée faut lier aux conifères
conviendra mieux pour une colline et au
début les jeunes pousses doivent être
replantés chaque année pour mieux
pousser c'est un travail qui nécessite
une approche méticuleuse contenu de la
difficulté de ce terrain montagneux je
dis adieu à ses travailleurs qui sauve
littéralement les montagnes et la main
et je descends dans la vallée je dois
voir le légume le cas le plus populaire
l'igname d'après ce que j'ai entendu on
le cultive dans les conditions très
difficiles
[Musique]
le comté de chant thing est réputée pour
ses produits agricoles
riz canne à sucre et des tubercules
comme celui ci sont cultivés ici
je n'aurais jamais cru que les ignames
où les patates douces comme on les
appelle souvent ressemble à ça il pousse
dans l'aude
les agriculteurs le cours m'ont expliqué
que les ignames avait besoin de beaucoup
d'eau sinon elles seront à mr
les tubercules sont arrosés si
généreusement que les champs dîner havre
semble souvent à démarrer les bottes en
caoutchouc sont nécessaires ici
le chant est planté en rangée oui nous
allons récolter par angers en commençant
de l'autre côté
un groupe de personnes en blouson blanc
arrive soudainement sur le terrain mais
il semble qu'on les attendait depuis
longtemps
ici nous sommes là et si
il s'agissait d'un employé de l'usiné en
panne que nous avons visité plus tôt ils
sont venus prélever des échantillons de
produits agricoles la société envoie ce
genre de groupes de travail partout dans
la province
nous partons du principe suivant
les produits de qualité proviennent des
matières premières et anglais la qualité
ils font attention à chaque détail
celui ci est trop petit ce n'est pas
bien mais celui là est très bien
il n'y a pas de plus de 20 cm est
considéré comme grand l'une des
principales questions est de savoir quel
genre d'engrais utilisent les
agriculteurs
de l'engrais que vous utilisez et in
naturelle naturelle organique et
le chant de kyoshin couet est petit il
fait à peine trois hectares et demi
néanmoins les ignames génère des revenus
annuels considérable cent mille yuan
soit plus de 14 mille de leurs parents
les résultats ont commencé à s'améliorer
lorsqu'une grande société
agroalimentaire est venu à son aide
avant que l'entreprise ne commence à
travailler sur ses terres aucun de nous
n'avait de maisons ou de voitures mais
avec l'arrivée de l'entreprise nos
revenus ont augmenté nous avons plus
donc nous permettre d'acheter maisons et
voitures lors une telle coopération
entre les géants industriels et les
petits agriculteurs profitent bien
entendu aux deux parties
l'agriculteur cultive des cultures
biologiques et il est bien payé pour
celle ci le fabricant de produits
alimentaires bénéficie d'un
approvisionnement en matières premières
de haute qualité
[Musique]
on
était chargé bon travail merci au revoir
tout le monde
monsieur go le chef de ce groupe de
travail apporte les échantillons
prélevés à l' usine on les attend en
laboratoire où ils seront l'objet des
tests approfondis
[Musique]
oh
les voilà
il faut décider de quel genre d' analyse
nous avons besoin nous mesurons la
teneur en eau et la valeur
nutritionnelle
l'igname est l'un des légumes les plus
populaires en chine et dans certaines
régions il est même considéré comme une
gourmandise
elles contiennent des acides aminés qui
sont essentiels à la vie humaine ils
sont également riches en amidon
protéines et vitamines c les ignames
contiennent également du fer du calcium
du zinc et divers acides aminés
lusine prévoit de lancer un nouveau
produit des bâtonnets de patates douces
sécher et il semble que les ignames
cultiver h anting conviennent
parfaitement
[Musique]
les résultats montrent que ces ignames
sont très nutritive
désormais le fermer kyo peut dormir
tranquille avec un partenaire comme
celui ci est le rêve sécuriser ses
commandes pour des années et tout cela
il le doit au programme du gouvernement
qui encourage à soutenir les plus
démunis au cours des dix dernières
années les grandes entreprises de
jinjiang ont investi 200 millions de
yuans dans l'économie de leurs protégés
de changxing
initialement xinxiang et des changxing à
éradiquer la pauvreté
mais maintenant les deux coopère plus
étroitement et se rendent des services
le président jean ping considère cela
comme on prend clé dans son rapport
l'expérience de changxing dans lequel il
souligne particulièrement la façon dont
tim chong et chongqing se sont unis dans
une lutte commune
ping est une chanson populaire cela veut
dire il faut se battre pour gagner mais
ce ne sont pas que des bonnes paroles
les chinois savent qu'il n'ya pas de
victoire sans combat il faut travailler
sans relâche pour assurer un avenir
confortable pour son pays comme pour soi
même comme on le dit dans les premières
lignes de cette chanson seul un tiers du
succès dépend du destin le reste de vos
efforts alosi
g
à
[Musique]
l'homme
n'est pas ma
vieira
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
temps d'antenne
m
je vais maintenant dire au revoir aux
villes de jinjiang et chan ting et je
vais continuer mon voyage à travers la
province de fujian il y a encore tant de
choses à voir